♪
>> Tucker: FINAL EXAM WAS
CANCELLED LAST NIGHT DUE TO
BREAKING NEWS FROM NORTH
KOREA.
BUT WE STILL HELD THE
COMPETITION.
BECAUSE THAT'S HOW WE ARE.
HERE'S WHAT HAPPENED.
♪
>> Tucker: OH, WE'RE OUT OF
TIME.
TIME FOR FINAL EXAM TWO NEWS
PROFESSIONALS FACE ONE
ANOTHER IN A BATTLE OF
KNOWLEDGE.
YOU CAN PLAY ALONG AT HOME
AS THEY DO.
JOINING US TONIGHT FOX CHIEF
NATIONAL CORRESPONDENT ED
HENRY.
HE WON THE BATTLE OF
DEFENDING CHAMPIONS LAST
WEEK AGAINST BRET BAIER.
QUITE A CONTEST.
HE GETS TO RETURN FOR
ANOTHER MATCHUP.
HIS CHALLENGER THIS WEEK FOX
WASHINGTON CORRESPONDENT OUR
OLD FRIEND GILLIAN TURNER.
YOU KNOW THE RULES AND FOR
THE SAKE OF CONSISTENCY.
EARN BUZZER.
WAIT UNTIL I FINISH ASKING
THE QUESTION IN ORDER TO DO
THAT.
EVERY CORRECT ANSWER IS
WORTH A POINT.
IF YOU GET IT WRONG, WE
DEDUCT A POINT FROM YOUR
TOTAL.
BEST OF FIVE WINS.
PLAYER.
>> INTERNATIONAL WOMEN'S
DAY.
>> Tucker: THESE ARE
INTERNATIONAL RULES, TOO.
>> I JUST THOUGHT YOU MIGHT
WANT TO MENTION THAT.
>> Tucker: ABSOLUTELY.
THAT DOES NOT GIVE YOU AN
ADVANTAGE.
HERE'S THE FIRST QUESTION.
AFTER WINNING THE ACADEMY
AWARD FOR BEST ACTRESS ON
SUNDAY NIGHT, FRANCIS
MCDOOR MITT HAD SOMETHING
UNUSUAL HAPPEN TO HER OSCAR
WHAT WAS IT?
ED HENRY.
>> SOME GUY STOLE IT.
>> Tucker: I DON'T BELIEVE
THAT SOME GUY STOLE IT
MAKING THIS UP.
QUOTE DID SOME GUY STEAL IT?
>> THIS MORNING, TERRY
BRYANT ISN'T CELEBRATING.
>> THANK YOU.
>> INSTEAD, CHARGED WITH
GRAND THEFT LARCENY AFTER
ALLEGEDLY SWIPING THE BEST
ACTRESS OSCAR FROM WINNER
FRANCIS McDOOR
FRANCIS McDORR
FRANCIS McDORMAND.
>> Tucker: SOME GUY STOLE IT
INDEED YOU ARE RIGHT.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT HIS JOB
WAS.
HE WAS BACK STAGE OR
SOMETHING.
>> Tucker: ABOUT $8.
>> I'M MAD I DIDN'T GET THAT
BECAUSE I DIDN'T WATCH THEM
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN 8
YEARS.
>> THE LARCENY DIDN'T HAPPEN
IN REALTIME.
>> Tucker: QUESTION NUMBER
TWO, ONE OF THE WORLD'S MOST
POPULAR SODAS ANNOUNCED THIS
WEEK THEY WILL SOON BE
SELLING THEIR FIRST EVER
ALCOHOLIC DRINK.
WHAT COMPANY IS IT?
SODA MAKER SELLING BOOZE.
CARE TO GUESS?
>> Tucker: THAT'S THE -- THE
JUDGES HAVE A HINT.
OKAY, I WILL GIVE IT BASED
IN ATLANTA.
ED HENRY?
>> COCA COLA.
COCA COLA HE SAYS OR COULD
IT BE 7 UP?
>> SOMETHING BREWING.
COCA COLA LAUNCH AS NEW
ALCOHOLIC DRINK IN JAPAN.
IT'S VERY FIRST ATTEMPT AT
BREAKING INTO THE BOOZE
BUSINESS AND MORE THAN 130
YEARS.
>> THIS IS GOING TO BE
CONTROVERSIAL.
>> Tucker: OF COURSE, IT WAS
IN JAPAN.
>> RIGHT, I DIDN'T SAY THAT.
>> Tucker: NO YOU DIDN'T BUT
YOU GOT COCA COLA.
>> YES, BOWERS I ASKED FOR A
HINT.
>> Tucker: YOU BOTH GOT THE
HINT TO BE FAIR THOUGH.
LET ME SAY I AM ROOTING FOR
YOU.
I HAVE NEVER GHOITED THAT.
DON'T BLAME ME.
QUESTION THREE, AT
SATURDAY'S GRIDIRON DINNER
AT WHICH BRET BAIER, BY THE
WAY PLAYED STARRING ROLE.
THE PRESIDENT ROASTED
WASHINGTON ELITE.
HE ZEROED IN ON ONE
CONGRESSMAN WOMAN FOR HER
CLAIM WE CAN SECURE OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER BY MOWING
THE GRASS THERE WHAT MEMBER
OF CONGRESS DID HE TARGET?
HE HAD HENRY?
>> Tucker: YOU ARE SAYING
NANCY PELOSI CLAIMED WE
COULD TIGHTEN OUR BORDERS BY
MOWING THE GRASS.
>> GRIDIRON DID I A STORY ON
THIS FOR SHANNON.
>> Tucker: WE WILL SEE IF
MEMORY SERVES.
>> WE ALL HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO PROTECT
OUR BORDERS.
SHOULD THERE BE FENCING?
SHOULD THERE BE TECHNOLOGY?
SHOULD THEY MOW THE GRASS SO
THAT PEOPLE CAN'T HIDE IN
IT?
>> Tucker: WOW, SHE REALLY
SAID THAT AND WE HAVE THE
TAPE.
>> RIGHT.
>> Tucker: CAN YOU STILL
TURN IT AROUND BY THE WAY,
JILLIAN.
YES, YOU CAN.
>> I CAN'T ANSWER ANY MORE.
BECAUSE I WILL LOSE POINTS.
>> Tucker: SEE IF YOU CAN
GET THIS ONE.
QUESTION FOUR, A ZOO IN
INDONESIA BEING CRITICIZED
BY ANIMAL RIGHTS ACTIVISTS.
VIDEO EMERGED THIS WEEK
SHOWING AN ORANGUTAN AT THE
ZOO DOING SOMETHING ONLY
ADULT HUMANS TYPICALLY DO.
WHAT WAS IT?
>> HINT?
>> Tucker: HINT, ARE YOU
READY?
HINT THE SURGEON GENERAL
DISAPPROVES.
GILLIAN TURNER.
>> ORANGUTAN CAUGHT SMOKING
AT THE ZOO.
SEE HIM SMOKING LIKE AN
EXPERIENCED SMOKER.
HE KNEW WHAT TO DO.
VISITOR THREW THE LIT
CIGARETTE.
HE LIKELY LEARNED HOW TO
SMOKE FROM WATCHING HUMANS.
ISN'T THAT CRAZY?
>> WHO GAVE HIM THE
CIGARETTE?
>> Tucker: I DON'T KNOW.
BUT THEY ARE HASSLING.
HAS TO STAND OUTSIDE THE
BUILDING WHEN HE SMOKES NOW.
PEOPLE ARE DOWN ON HIM.
REALLY?
ANYWAY.
FINAL QUESTION, IF YOU DRIVE